hello everybody hope that you're good
today is the last trading day of the
week for me because you guys know that I
don't trade on the weekend at least not
to bitcoin if I do I usually trade
altcoins so today's going to be the
lasting day of the week for me most
likely
um yesterday's uh trading setup you can
see that it played out that's the
liquidity pool that was for Target 26
820.
and you can see the price bounced okay
we were saying that we were under this
resistance the 50 main the one hour time
frame and we were expecting some kind of
a shorter squeeze to the upside all
right and then is when you have here the
liquidity pool completely retraced okay
so that was a good setup let's try to
find another setup for today I'll tell
you what happened this morning okay I
woke up
I logged into trading View and I looked
at the chart and I stay away
I saw this week over here okay so let me
Mark it for you guys
that is the week okay you have here the
100 of the week let me market for you
a hundred percent of the week
okay in yellow
16. that's how usually like to Market
um clone
and here 50 percent
all right so that's uh imbalance in the
chart there are if the Enterprise will
likely come back to okay uh now we have
our Target hopefully they can fill the
week today and once you have the target
I always tell you now you have to try to
find your entry point okay so uh that
liquidity pool here is filled you see
this week here I got fill and now you
have to try to figure it out what some
they might attack first before the week
all right so if you're going to the 15
minutes time frame
let's try to figure out something okay
let's try to find something here
um okay I see another week here at the
highs
all right
I see it doesn't fifty percent that's
100 so I see that week there
will give you notice it was uh retracing
this liquidity pool here
let's try to find more things one more
time frame
okay
um I mean this could be
this could be another small
here liquid to pull there
okay that is not
that is not finished
so uh what I would say is that most
likely with my tea today I'm going to
remove this Target because it's uh to
close I think it's likely that we see
Spike up first
okay maybe sweep the size
and then go towards the week okay and
that would be maybe a pump towards 26
800.
before
26 300 okay that's what I think at the
moment but of course you have to think
that the result of liquid to the upside
okay because you have here
this large liquidity pool over here
that's around twenty seven thousand five
hundred okay and also you have a week
here
right this week over here so there are
some targets to the upside bow because
we have a week here okay if price pumps
here
we're not going to truth this pump
because we think that there is an
imbalance
left in the chart so it makes more sense
the price recovers this imbalance and
then it can pump if it wants to okay
so now that we have the main idea of the
trade of the day okay that would be a
pump first hopefully right at the start
of the New York session and with that I
mean between ideally between two and
four PM uh UTC time because then we
would have time to see this retrace okay
in the same session and that would be uh
two percent pump sorry two percent move
for Bitcoin so that would be a very nice
trade now you have to think about the
motivation of this idea okay because if
you have no invalidation you know when
you think about right you have to think
about the target
does it take profits the entry point and
the valuation okay when you're gonna
cool that trade why are you gonna leave
that trade when you're gonna exit if you
don't like what you are saying okay and
in my opinion in this case it's in the
four hour time frame okay you have here
the 50ma you can see that it acted as
resistance here
all right so uh what you don't want to
see in my opinion is the price let me
remove this please
so it's more clear what you don't want
to see is this pump first okay more fine
until then and then a retrace and that
we hold
the 50 main default or something because
if we hold that level during the retrace
and we don't go lower
okay
that means that we're going to have
another bounce
and that would take us maybe to twenty
seven thousand two hundred you have here
another liquidity pool in this one here
okay
so that's what you have to be careful
with uh we have to stress scenarios in
my opinion uh because you know you have
the many scenario
which is go to 2600 ish and then retrace
towards this week straight away okay but
time frame holds then we're gonna switch
into a long position okay
and we're gonna aim for this one here
that's so far what I can see in the
chart
um so I'm not gonna go into hybrid
Capital because we did that yesterday
there is a lot of liquidity between 27
500.
okay and 28
200y it's very simple let me show you
all these imbalances there are a lot of
imbalances first of all
you have here this liquidity pool here
also you go another liquidity pool here
and of course you have a week
over here okay these are the levels in
the chart to the upside to the opposite
there are also some levels I'm not going
to lie to you because geography are also
liquidity pool
all right
but
if you check High block Capital there
has been liquidation CR for quite some
time so I've been telling you we're
expecting these zones to get taken
sooner or later okay that's all you have
to be very careful with the source at
the moment in my opinion even if the
chart is looking better here
all right and you are under resistance
you have to be very cautious because as
soon as you see a move like this okay
and you flip resistance into support
then that's when you can start seeing
price
attacking this one's High okay so that's
what I mean I'm gonna try today to take
that short
around 26 826 700 or so but as soon as I
see something like this
then I'm gonna quit my trade okay all
I'm gonna favor higher prices it's as
simple as that okay before I finish the
video I want to remind you that you can
trade immediate it's an exchange that
doesn't require kyc and if you register
with the link in the description you're
gonna get five dollars bonus for free
also any deposits between two hundred
dollars and a thousand dollars get uh
ten percent payback so that means like
if you for example
deposit let's say four hundred dollars
they're gonna get forty dollars for free
all right uh ten percent payback and
also well if you deposit a bigger amount
you get bigger rewards of course and
anybody that deposits at least a hundred
dollars is going to participate in the
next giveaways for the trading course
for free last week we did a giveaway of
10 winners for the trading course in
July and we'll do new ones soon so
that's pretty much everything I want to
say guys thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon